Quand la santé du pape est compromise,
on l’emmène immédiatement…
…bah à l’hôpital !
On ne l’emmène pas à l’Église,
on ne fait pas venir un exorciste ;
non,
on met son sort
entre les mains d’un médecin
MATÉRIALISTE.
Pourtant…
il est censé croire à la guérison spirituelle,
le pape…
Ça, pour Nassim Nicholas Taleb,
c’est la preuve que le pape lui-même
n’est pas prêt à assumer
les risques de sa foi.
Ses actes ne sont donc pas cohérents
avec ses idées.
Mais c’est là un cas extrême
de la condition humaine.
Nous sommes TOUS
animés par l’aversion au risque
- c’est très humain.
OR,
nous avons en réalité intérêt
à aller contre notre nature
- à prendre davantage de risques.
Je suis Romain,
voici Haristote,
et vous êtes sur 1000 idées de culture générale.
J’ai lu récemment Skin in the game,
traduit par « Jouer sa peau »,
de Nassim Nicholas Taleb
- et même si je ne suis pas d’accord avec
tout,
j’ai adoré.
Cet essai provocateur réhabilite la sagesse
du risque
dans notre monde où
la protection,
la stabilité et la garantie
sont si valorisées.
La thèse est d’autant plus originale
que Nassim Taleb
est un trader
devenu philosophe
- oui oui,
vous avez bien entendu.
Il a même fait fortune dans la finance
grâce à ses idées philosophiques
qui sont centrées sur l’incertitude.
Dans cette vidéo,
je vais vous exposer quelles sont,
d’après lui,
les cinq raisons de prendre des risques
- et vous allez voir que la cinquième
est étonnante.
Comme je le fais systématiquement
depuis les quelques vidéos précédentes,
je vous permets de télécharger mes notes
de lecture,
en cliquant sur le lien
qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
ou sur celui qui est dans la description,
puis en me laissant votre adresse e-mail.
Petite précision :
ne soyez pas étonnés
si les citations que vous trouvez
dans ces notes de lecture,
dans cette vidéo,
ou dans l’article de blog
ne sont pas dans le livre
ou dans les résumés qu’on trouve sur internet
- c’est juste qu’au moment
de commander le livre Kindle,
j’ai été un peu « pince » :
comme la version anglaise était moins chère,
je me suis dit
« Oh, ça ira »,
et en fait
ça a été assez difficile à traduire
parce que Nassim Taleb a un style très particulier,
et qu’il crée même
des expressions et des concepts.
Donc avec le recul,
j’ai fait une bêtise,
et puis je vous dis surtout ça
pour que vous sachiez
que les extraits que j’ai retenus
ne sont pas issus de la version française,
mais de ma galère de traducteur.
Ce que vous pouvez faire
pour me consoler de tout ce temps perdu,
c’est donner un pouce bleu à la vidéo,
et puis vous abonner
si vous aimez la vulgarisation de la pensée.
Après ces précisions,
on peut commencer.
La première raison de prendre des risques,
c’est...
Quand marchais avec Haristote le long de la
mer,
au début,
il restait souvent près de l’eau ;
puis,
un jour de tempête,
il a reçu une grosse vague
- et il fait trois kilos hein -
à tel point que j’ai craint
qu’il soit emporté.
Depuis
- vous me voyez venir -
il reste relativement loin de l’eau,
et il est très méfiant
lorsque la mer est agitée.
Nassim Taleb cite le proverbe grec
pathemata mathemata,
que j’ai traduit par
« Ce qui a été souffert a été appris
».
En clair,
on apprend par soi-même
en prenant le risque
de recourir à une certaine manière de faire
- on en subit les conséquences,
puis on ajuste le tir,
parfois radicalement,
comme Haristote
qui a été traumatisé par une vague.
D’après Nassim Taleb,
ce phénomène fondamental
devrait nous inviter à nous méfier
des experts en tout genre
- fitness,
lifestyle,
sommeil,
respiration -
SAUF
s’ils prennent un risque
en faisant dépendre leur rétribution
de la performance de la personne
qu’ils conseillent.
Mais fondamentalement,
l’efficacité de leur enseignement
dépend de la pratique,
parce qu’il faut toujours
prendre le risque d’échouer,
de stagner,
voire d’être ridicule,
pour progresser
et apprendre.
La sagesse populaire connaît bien ce phénomène
:
« On apprend de ses erreurs.
»
Moi, par exemple,
comme j’ai suffisamment souffert à traduire
ce livre,
je ne préférerai plus la version anglaise
pour économiser cinq euros.
D’après Nassim Taleb,
si votre chirurgien ressemble à celui-ci…
vous devez vous méfier.
En revanche,
si vous pouvez le confondre avec un boucher…
là c’est bon signe.
Pourquoi donc
faudrait-il choisir
celui qui vous fait peur ?
Parce que s’il prend le risque d’effrayer
ses patients,
c’est qu’il compense largement la défiance
qu’il vous inspire
par un surcroît de compétence.
Tandis qu'avec le chirurgien
en mode George Clooney,
c’est le surcroît de confiance
que vous inspire son apparence,
qui compense
un possible défaut de compétence,
OU MÊME une négligence,
une moindre qualité de service,
due à la confiance excessive
que vous placez en lui.
Il y aurait donc plus généralement,
selon Nassim Taleb,
un arbitrage
- pour parler comme les économistes -
entre la compétence
et l’apparence.
Une apparence excessivement soignée,
et conforme à la fonction,
indiquerait probablement
un défaut de compétence ;
et à l’inverse,
le professionnel très compétent peut,
lui,
prendre le risque de négliger son apparence.
« Le contact avec la réalité filtre l’incompétence,
écrit Taleb,
parce que la réalité est aveugle aux apparences.
»
Je ne suis pas du tout d’accord,
en revanche,
quand il transpose cet arbitrage
à la parole,
écrite comme orale.
Il affirme que les personnes
que l’on comprend le plus facilement
sont des menteurs ;
or,
à mon modeste avis,
il confond peut-être la clarté du discours
avec l’effet du discours
- je suis d’accord pour dire
qu’un discours éblouissant
peut être fallacieux,
en revanche,
un discours clair
l’est probablement beaucoup moins
parce qu’il est très facile,
de par sa clarté,
d’évaluer sa pertinence.
Et puis,
dans ma modeste expérience,
ce sont surtout la complexité
et le jargon
qui servent à dissimuler
les déficiences de fond.
Mais bon,
c’est un détail.
Ce que vous devez retenir,
c’est que si votre chirurgien,
c’est lui…
…il va faire les choses bien.
À New York,
les acteurs de Broadway
aiment à se retrouver chez Lindy,
un traiteur,
pour discuter des pièces.
Et ils ont remarqué un truc :
c’est qu’un show programmé pour cent
jours,
dure généralement
cent jours de plus.
Ce que ça veut dire,
au niveau théorique,
c’est que la durée de vie restante de certaines
choses
serait liée à leur durée de vie passée.
Si on revient à l’exemple du show de Broadway,
il a de bonnes chances de durer
cent jours de plus
au bout de cent jours,
parce le fait
qu’il n’ait pas déjà été déprogrammé
prouve qu’il plaît au public,
ET DONC
qu’il trouvera probablement encore
des spectateurs supplémentaires.
Si on généralise :
plus les choses non périssables
- et en particulier les idées,
les hypothèses scientifiques -
plus ces choses durent,
c’est-à-dire plus elles survivent longtemps,
plus elles sont robustes
à la critique et à la réfutation,
DONC plus elles ont de chances
d’être vraies.
C’est « l’effet Lindy »,
du nom du traiteur
prisé par les acteurs de Broadway.
Pour découvrir la vérité,
il faut donc soumettre l’hypothèse au risque
de la critique
et de la réfutation.
Alors le temps fera son oeuvre,
et par le darwinisme du monde intellectuel,
seules les idées pertinentes survivront.
Le problème,
selon Nassim Taleb,
c’est qu’il existe de gens qui ont intérêt
à entraver cette émergence darwinienne
de la vérité.
L’universitaire
pour lequel seul compte
l’avis de ses pairs ;
le journaliste,
qui écrit surtout…
…pour les journalistes ;
ou encore Thomas Piketty,
dont l’autorité intellectuelle reposerait
sur la connivence des mandarins.
Mais je m’arrête là,
parce que je vais vous proposer
un petit best-of
des attaques de Nassim Taleb
en conclusion de la vidéo.
Alors vous vous souvenez :
avant d’être traumatisé par une vague,
Haristote se baladait près de l’eau ;
MAIS pourquoi n’a-t-il jamais
sauté dans la mer ?
Il aurait pu,
parce qu’elle n’est généralement
pas très agitée.
Eh bien c’est simplement
que son instinct
- une forme de connaissance
hérité de générations immémoriales
de chihuahuas -
son instinct lui dit
que c’est dangereux
de plonger dans la mer.
Parmi les chihuahuas
qui ont pris le risque un jour,
une partie,
- probablement la majorité vu leur taille
-
n’ont pas survécu
- et ceux qui sont sortis vivants
de la première baignade
ont ensuite survécu
PARCE qu’ils en ont tiré
l’expérience du danger.
J’ai évoqué,
pour la troisième raison de prendre des risques,
le darwinisme du savoir,
mais le risque joue bien sûr aussi un rôle
dans le darwinisme
du monde matériel.
C’est le risque qui filtre les comportements,
et sépare ceux favorables à la survie
et ceux qui ne le sont pas.
« Tout ne survient pas pour une raison,
écrit Taleb,
mais tout ce qui survit
survit pour une raison »
Par exemple,
il a fallu que beaucoup d’avions se crashent
avant que les vols ne soient
aussi sûrs qu’aujourd’hui.
Alors,
c’est vrai à l’échelle collective
et sur des générations,
MAIS AUSSI à l’échelle de l’être vivant,
et dans un laps de temps court,
parce que l’être vivant
adapte son comportement
en fonction de son expérience du risque.
Par exemple,
Haristote s’est brûlé
une seule fois
en tenant de voler de la nourriture
dans une poêle chaude,
et aujourd’hui il se méfie de ce récipient.
Chez les humains,
la nécessité du risque pour la survie
explique par exemple
la dangerosité de l’administrateur,
qui est généralement protégé du risque
- il se contente de le transférer,
ce qui empêche l’émergence
des meilleures solutions.
« Vous ne convaincrez jamais quelqu’un
qu’il a tort,
écrit Taleb ;
seule la réalité le peut ».
Ainsi,
d’un côté,
le risque sélectionne les idées
et les comportements
favorables à la survie ;
et de l’autre,
la déconnexion du risque
pérennise l’inefficacité,
l’inefficience,
et le danger.
MAIS AUSSI...
…la laideur morale.
Vous savez ce que fera Nassim Taleb
si vous lui volez sa place de parking ?
Il va sortir son téléphone,
et vous filmer.
A priori,
ça devrait vous faire réfléchir ;
ça devrait révéler
que vous n’assumez pas réellement
le risque lié à votre action.
Cet exemple montre que le risque
a une portée morale.
Nassim Taleb développe notamment deux dimensions
:
la première,
c’est le risque de la publicité de l’acte
- comme avec la vidéo
du vol de la place de parking -
parce que la publicité de l'acte
révèle si on l’assume,
ou non.
De ce point de vue,
il faut reconnaître le courage
des personnes qui expriment publiquement
des opinions controversées
- un peu comme Nassim Taleb,
qui n’a va pas avec le dos de la cuillère.
La seconde dimension
de la portée morale du risque,
c’est la cohérence des idées,
des paroles et des actes.
Vous vous souvenez de mon accroche :
le pape,
qui prêche la force de l’esprit,
ne se soigne pourtant pas
par la prière.
Et il y a plein d'autres exemples :
les millionnaires anticapitalistes,
ou les rentiers
qui prêchent la prise de risque,
les écologistes extrémistes
qui ne vivent pas dans la forêt ;
les restaurateurs qui ne consomment pas
leurs propres produits ;
les conseillers en tous genres
qui n’appliquent pas leurs propres conseils.
Encore une fois,
Nassim Taleb a ses têtes de turc,
mais c’est l’être humain,
en général,
qui a tendance à plus parler
qu’il n’agit,
et à ne pas traduire en actes,
ses convictions
et ses paroles.
Or,
Taleb écrit :
« si votre vie privée contredit vos opinions
intellectuelles,
cela annule vos idées intellectuelles,
pas votre vie privée.
[…]
Si vos actions privées ne sont pas généralisables,
alors vous ne pouvez pas avoir d’idées
générales ».
Du coup,
on peut en déduire trois règles
pour mener une vie honorable
- elles ne sont pas données explicitement
dans le livre,
c’est moi qui synthétise :
première règle :
agir avant de parler,
et préférer l’action à la parole
pour se confronter au monde réel ;
deuxième règle :
ne théoriser qu’avec prudence
et humilité ;
enfin,
troisième règle :
vivre les conséquences
de ses idées.
L’action est supérieure à la parole
parce que c’est elle
qui contraint l’homme
à assumer le risque
inhérent à la réalité.
FACTA
NON
VERBA
Je peux résumer la vidéo
avec une toute petite phrase :
le risque est un filtre.
Il filtre l’erreur,
le danger,
l’incompétence,
et même
la malhonnêteté.
Plus fondamentalement,
vivre,
c’est connaître le risque,
alors autant l’embrasser.
Allez,
je passe au best-of des attaques de Nassim
Taleb.
Mais tout d’abord,
je veux bien un pouce bleu
- si la vidéo vous a plu,
bien sûr -
et puis abonnez-vous à la chaîne
si vous aimez la vulgarisation de la pensée.
Alors,
pour Nassim Taleb :
Robert Rubin,
l’ancien patron de la banque Citigroup,
qui s’est considérablement enrichi
en l’ayant menée au bord de la faillite,
est l’incarnation même de l’aléa moral,
c’est-à-dire le fait de ne pas assumer
les conséquences
des risques qu’on prend ;
les administrateurs sont,
dans le privé comme dans le public,
un fléau ;
les expatriés des multinationales
sont des esclaves haut de gamme ;
le salarié est un chien domestique
comparé à l’entrepreneur,
qui est un loup sauvage ;
MAIS
l’entrepreneur qui prend des risques
avec l’argent d’investisseurs
est un lâche ;
les élites modernes
sont constituées d’intellectuels idiots
;
Thomas Piketty
et les intellectuels académiques
sont des donneurs de leçon
qui vivent dans leur microcosme ;
les chercheurs se prostituent ;
l’économie
est une fausse science ;
l’éducation supérieure américaine
est un racket ;
les philanthropes
sont des vaniteux ;
les experts de la géopolitique
sont de faux savants ;
ET LUI,
Nassim Taleb ?
Un preneur de risques.
Merci d’avoir regardé la vidéo jusqu’au
bout !
J’espère vraiment qu’elle vous a plu.
Pour ma part,
j’ai pris plaisir
- mis à part l’effort de traduction -
à lire Jouer sa peau
de Nassim Taleb.
Alors,
vous pouvez m’aider,
et m'encourager
À PRENDRE LE RISQUE
de faire de nouvelles vidéos,
et à tenter de nouvelles choses,
de trois manières
qui sont compatibles :
premièrement,
en donnant un pouce bleu à la vidéo ;
deuxièmement,
en vous abonnant à la chaîne
SI vous aimez la vulgarisation
de la pensée ;
et troisièmement,
en laissant un petit commentaire.
Je vous permets également
de télécharger
mes notes de lectures,
comme je le fais systématiquement
depuis les quelques vidéos précédentes.
Si vous voulez ma synthèse écrite détaillée
du livre
qui est sur le blog,
ou si vous souhaitez le lire directement,
tous les liens sont dans la description.
Je suis Romain,
je suis avec mon fidèle Haristote,
et sous étiez
sur 1000 idées de culture générale.
Prenez le risque de vous intéresser
au meilleur de la pensée,
MAIS sans vous prendre la tête.